welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the most fascinating
discoveries from our derivatives world
or reward focused on what else the
weapons we realized that Thor might have
reforged meal near with an updated
worthiness charm that will be the key to
door for more for ever and the new
shield of Captain America gate falcon
might be made of Wolverines labored
adamantium or as our inlets keyboard
spelled it at a medium but there's one
crucial weapon we've overlooked that
made the survival of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe possible Tony Stark's
Infinity Gauntlet also known as the iron
gauntlet or the Nano gauntlet the god
likes that for Hulk so perfectly fit
that you can't acquit a recreation of
the Infinity Gauntlet that Thanos forced
a tree to forge out of aruond middle ear
before cutting off his forging hands now
we have discussed how stark designed it
with ingenious upgrades namely
compatibility with his own mark 85 armor
allowing him to sneakily absorb the
stones and trick Thanos with the
universe's greatest mr. X but what we
haven't talked about is the deep blue
even more brilliant design element
buried in this gauntlets blueprints
something B just discovered that reveals
his whole evolution and transformation
as they weapons manufacturer throughout
the Infinity Saga and something that I
believe will return an upcoming Marvel
phase for titles like shang-chi and a
legend of the ten rings in ways that
will literally blow the big new detail I
spotted during a recent rewatch of the
Avengers endgame final battle which I
honestly never noticed despite spending
more time with this movie then I will
any loved one in my life is this the
Russos camerawork deliberately leaves
the fate of the stark gauntlet a mystery
see I had assumed that stark Scotland uh
stood along with Thanos himself the way
Pat's nap victims weaponry and clothes
tend to dust with them like Bucky's arm
the suits of black panther and
spider-man all the ships and Thanos's
fleet a clean slate check out the final
seconds of Thanos his existence he
staggers to the right and stark Scotland
remains visible and frame until right as
the frame pushes in past the edge of the
gauntlet and that second is when Thanos
starts to disintegrate from his
shoulders we never actually see the
gauntlet itself dust in the
decision of the timing of this shot they
anis is Dustin only starting right after
we could no longer see the gauntlet and
frame tells me this had to be
intentional either the Russos and the
VFX team didn't want to make any
conclusive decisions to leave the door
open for future filmmakers to pick up
this loose right if they want or Marvel
Studios from the top had some ideas for
ways they might want to reuse this
weapon honestly why not both the editing
even masks the audio so that the moment
you would expect to hear the gauntlet
thud to the ground we cut to Tony taking
his final steps now assuming that this
gauntlet did not disintegrate it's
survival actually is more important to
the Institute's future than you might
think like think about it this is now
the single most important weapon in this
fictional human history everyone would
want to get their hands on it actually
in the final minutes of the movie you
can see a clean up operation and I am
very curious what is then that
helicopters cargo and who's flying it
but here's what I love about how stark
designed this gauntlet he absolutely
accounted for this this is a guy who has
spent his entire adult hood cleaning up
after his own inventions were weaponized
outside of his control his Jericho
missiles the mark 1 Iron Monger armor
ain't Ron in the iron Legion
sadly posthumously even Edith in his
drones but with these stark gauntlets
Tony Stark finally invented the ultimate
efficient weapon a weapon that fires
once and never again which everything
about it is exactly what he told us he
wanted in the first movie they say the
best weapon is one you never have to
fire I prefer the weapon you only have
to fire once and I submit to you that
despite the very entertaining desperate
rugby hand off of the end game final
battle
this whole scramble was a misdirect a
necessary misdirect but a misdirect
nonetheless because had Santos or any of
his minions gotten the hold of that
gauntlet even with all six stones locked
and loaded and snapped with it still it
would not have worked it would have
resulted in the same impotent snap as an
empty gauntlet maybe even worse well
before we continue thanks to Bing energy
for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine if
sugar-free has zero calories you get it
to screw with over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is purple guava pear you can
really taste the purple in it also the
guava and the pear but the purple people
when I'm feeling sluggish a can of bang
energy purple helps pick me up so I can
charge her the rest of the day check out
bang on Instagram you can get two to one
to five percent off your order at Banga
- energy calm when you use a code in new
rock stars 25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea
keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff - beer about to bang self
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using their code and
new rock stars 25 so during the in-game
final battle you may wonder why no one
simply puts on the gauntlet earlier does
what Tony Stark eventually had to do
everyone had their hands on this thing
and they all had ample opportunities to
do this Captain Marvel and Wanda
Maximoff were definitely powerful enough
to sustain the energy surge both their
powers were derived from Infinity stones
coursing through their veins it's the
same gamma radiation that banner claimed
primed his Anatomy to be able to wield
it and don't tell me that Tony Stark was
the only vendor who could sacrifice
themselves Hawkeye was definitely ready
to take himself out on Boromir Thor
begged to make the snap but I guess was
told he was too drunk and cap loves
jumping on grenades but you'll even
notice multiple times they could have
gone boar the gauntlet and they
deliberately chose not to cap ignores it
Oni ignores it the reason is because
Stark's gauntlet was now defunct as a
weapon it was a firecracker that was
already ignited blown up and is now just
a husk heckled at by all the dog owners
in the neighborhood you just woke up
that thing enlarged stupid hoax big
sausage fingers it did its job it
expired and it never changed its shape
thereafter vanish was able to fit his in
there because he and Hulk have the same
size hints that might be why Tony wanted
hope to do it not Thor see by comparison
Thanos is guru gauntlet from infinity
war could be used again and again after
the big snap despite the damage that was
done to it they anos used it to undo the
damage from Stormbreaker to his chest
he used it to portal way and of course
and in gained he used the stones to
destroy the stones to atomize them but
Unni ingeniously used that design
expectation back against Thanos and
Tony's design of the new start gauntlet
see Tony knew that after Hulk snapped
with the stones this gauntlet can never
be snapped again that's why you none of
the Avengers tried to put it on it's
little more than a suitcase for them to
just transport the stones but Tony also
knew that Thanos wouldn't try to use the
gauntlet again because that's how that
guru got what works see reminded the
clock to before the time heist Tony must
have anticipated that their mission
might cause them to cross paths with the
mad Titan sometime in the past and
that's exactly what happened
2014 Thanos scanned nebula to see his
future gauntlet quest and decide to
intervene in so Tony knew that Thanos
would be focused on the gauntlet the
weapon itself but not the ammo the
stones we even see this when Thanos
confronts Captain Marvel they lock horns
the gauntlet eight glowing Thanos has to
freaking take the Power Stone out of
that gauntlet and these that hit Carroll
and he should have known at that point
that this gauntlet sucks
that's why Tony doesn't go got a
gauntlet he tackles they an OC let's
Bandos take the default gauntlet so that
Tony can discreetly use his compatible
nanobots to absorb the stones onto a
hidden second gauntlets that still works
in his own suit before Thanos can
realize what's going on and then a boom
so with that gauntlet arm of Tony's mark
85 armor plus the undusted stark
gauntlet drop by Thanos
that leaves two single you Scott 'let's
to collect dust in this new world
a pair of forever locked relics for the
next generation to marvel over but
that's it
because Tony made sure that no one would
ever be able to do with these gauntlets
what the ten rings tried to do with this
Jericho missile tech and that brings us
back to shang-chi which is confirmed to
bring back the ten rings terrorist
network from that first Ironman film now
led by the true Mandarin now famously
the Mandarin from the comics seeks to
wield v10 Makluan rings mystical alien
tech not unlike the Infinity stones so
perhaps the ten rings will try to get
their hands on these two discarded
relics from the Battle of Earth and they
might assume that both are capable of
wielding and weaponizing their ten
pieces of alien mystical tech you might
see where I'm going with this because
the MCU
has compared infinity stone tech in the
past to the famous MacGuffin of Raiders
of the Lost Ark the Ark of the Covenant
so this orb has a real shiny blue
suitcase Ark of the Covenant Maltese
Falcons sort of vibe this is the part
where you know spikes come out with
skeletons on the end of them and
everything what are you talking when you
break into a place called the Temple of
the Power Stone there's gonna be a bunch
of booby traps okay go ahead
so perhaps Stark booby-trapped his
single-use gauntlets to backfire on
anyone who tries to use them again
including the ten rings the way the Ark
of the Covenant was rigged to doom the
unworthy who did not respect its power
[Music]
in case I'm not being clear I just want
shang-chi to end with him trying to
fight the Mandarin in the Mandarin
laughs maniacally lifts two retrofitted
Tony Stark armor pieces housing that ten
rings across his fingers tries to make
this and his head explodes I mean it
would be quite to be mind blowing way
for the Mandarin to go out right comment
down below with your thoughts on this
theory and where you think this gauntlet
just gonna end up next and for more
Theory discussion join our official
discord server which you can join by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars follow me on instagram at
a loss follow new rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching boom
[Music]